your boys done playing this is gone for  now training for the Olympic training  for the street  action  matter  Wong Jack man we leave in the Shaolin  Temple  check out come through in America people  in Chinatown don't like that I teach  whites Shaolin said Wong Jack man to spy  on he may be the only person in this  world who can tear down everything I've  been working so hard to build up sooner  or later  gonna have to fight him what is secretly  teaching he teaches us to kick ass she  can your technique is impressive but it  has one limitation what you on the  future  you're the path your relevant wall fight  me  accept our challenge wait for the end  never doubt man  but it makes it or breaks no rules no  hosts ball no limit to guys kill each  other  now you begin to reach serial limit one  minute  never show you my wonders punched on  you